(waves splashing)
- [Narrator] When you think of islands,
you might think of pristine
beaches and palm trees
gently swing along with a warm breeze.
Sounds like paradise.
And as a scientist,
islands are my kind of place for research.
Islands are very beautiful
and they also have a lot of biodiversity.
Biodiversity can be described
as the variety of species in an ecosystem.
Now, some ecosystems have
higher biodiversity than others,
but all ecosystems have a variety
of species that interact in specific ways
with one another.
Islands have such a variety of species
that they're often called
biodiversity hotspots.
They're home to so many diverse species,
much more so than the continents.
There are nearly half a million
islands around the world,
but they only make up about
5% of the Earth's land area.
Yet, islands are home to 20%
of the world's plant species
and 15% of all mammal,
bird and amphibian species.
Many of these island
species can only be found
on one island or within
a group of islands.
For example, you can only find the 'i'iwi,
a honeycreeper bird species,
in the main Hawaiian islands
in the North Pacific Ocean.
(birds chirping)
The 'i'iwi are important
pollinator species
for Hawaiian plants, including the 'opelu
and and the 'ohi'a.
Pollination is an essential
part of plant reproduction
allowing plants to produce
their fruits and seeds.
While the 'i'iwi feeds on the
sweet nectar of these plants,
this bird also helps to
support the next generation
of 'opelu and 'ohi'a.
These and other types of interactions
are happening all the time
between species in an ecosystem.
You can think of biodiversity
as a sort of safety net,
with each species as a knot,
and the ropes between knots
as their interactions.
The diversity of species
and their interactions,
hold the net together
allowing the ecosystem to function.
Plus, the relationships between
species are often unique.
For example, the 'i'iwi
has a special curved bill,
and it's evolved to feed on the nectar
of very specific flowers
that are similarly curved.
Like the 'opelu.
Now, even though the 'i'iwi
is highly adapted to its
environment, if something happens
to the 'opelu or 'ohi'a and
the plants start to decline,
it can spell disaster for the 'i'iwi.
When an ecosystem changes so much
that a species can no longer survive?
That species may become
extinct or die out,
causing biodiversity to decrease.
And unfortunately, many
of Hawaii's honeycreepers
and overall biodiversity have
been lost through extinction.
In the past, there were
at least 20 other species
of honeycreeper found across Hawaii,
but many of them have
become extinct over time.
If we return to our
analogy of biodiversity
as a safety net?
Whenever a species goes extinct
it's like a knot becomes undone
and parts of the net start to fall apart.
A decrease in biodiversity
is often a result of human activities
which is especially clear
in the Hawaiian Islands.
In the last few hundred
years, agriculture, grazing,
logging and development
have taken almost half
of Hawaii's forest cover.
And along with it, a big
part of its biodiversity.
Humans have also brought
non-native animals like rats
and feral pigs to Hawaii,
which have changed or
destroyed native habitats.
Plus, new diseases and climate change
have led to the extinction
of many Hawaiian species.
When an ecosystem loses biodiversity,
it doesn't function as well.
If 'ohi'a starts to disappear
from Hawaiian forests?
It's not just the 'i'iwi
that loses an important food source,
but the entire ecosystem is affected.
In fact, scientists often look
at how complete an
ecosystem's biodiversity is
in order to measure
the ecosystem's health.
The safety net of
biodiversity is supported
by having lots of different species,
which allows the ecosystem to cope
with natural disasters like
drought, storms and disease.
With more biodiversity,
ecosystems are stronger
and more resilient so
they can recover quickly.
But, with less biodiversity,
ecosystems become more vulnerable.
I told you a lot about how
Hawaii is losing biodiversity,
however, there is cause for some hope.
The nene, or Hawaiian
goose, nearly went extinct.
There were less than 30 birds
in the wild 50 years ago.
Now, thanks to lots of conservation work
to improve the habitat for those species,
there are over 3,000 nene
throughout the islands.
We humans are part of
earth's biodiversity too.
We are components of
the ecosystems we touch.
So if we have the power
to hurt these ecosystems,
we have the power to
protect and heal them too.
Aloha.